[Music]
we heard a cry out in the universe we
believe he is and we're here to help you
find a man one of the most highly
anticipated films of the year is almost
here a wrinkle in time opens two weeks
from today but only we have a special
look behind the scenes at what makes
this movie so magical yes
wrinkle in time is a journeying story
discovering about your own self and
about worlds that are bigger than you be
a heart okay
it took over four hours to get into her
full makeup and costumes which included
ten wigs and countless metallic corseted
gowns missus which for me she was a
cross between Maya Angelou and Glinda
the Good Witch from The Wizard of Oz so
you have a little bit of Glinda and then
you have a lot of Maya and so you
combine the two and put me in the center
as the vessel for it and you get mrs.
which it's find your father
so just how did Oprah come to join Reese
Witherspoon and Mindy Kaling as three
wise witches well it turns out she
wanted to vacay in New Zealand to watch
director Ava Duvernay at work she said
well if you're gonna do that why don't
you read for one of the roles and I said
lady oh and Reese just joined a new mom
Mindy at Disneyland
but it's this photo shop Vanity Fair
picture that Jimmy Kimmel wanted answers
for do you have a third hand we don't
know I've been trying to keep that a
secret
this year I mean Annie Leibovitz sent me
an apology like it's okay Annie it's all
right but I have a third hand thank God
any lip of us isn't doing surgery I
guess
you